okay holy [ __ ] guys Riot Games just
dropped a cluster bomb I'm not only the
eSports world but the gaming world at
large
last night they announced their own FPS
their own tactical card game their own
fighting game a [ __ ] anime for God's
sakes
and yes major changes to the actual game
League of Legends now I really want to
talk about the shooting game but my
expertise in the other genres are a
little varied so for those I brought in
some ringers first off is daniel rossen
who's gonna talk to us about the
fighting game and the anime it's not a
[ __ ] anime then there's Keith's cap
stick who's gonna tell us all about the
car game League of Legends itself and
team fight tactics try not to fall
asleep during that part I know falling
asleep randomly can be a pretty big
problem for someone as old as you go
alright so that's enough of an intro
roll the title card and let's get into
it
all right let's start this thing off
with the biggest announcement of the
bunch and that is obviously League of
Legends eSport manager
just kidding on obviously talking about
the FPS they call it project a a
character-based tactical shooter now
right away when you hear the phrase
character based and you see some of the
early gameplay where the character model
is throwing magic spheres at people I
started to think oh no this is gonna be
an overwatch clone but don't worry I
actually don't think that's what we're
dealing with you see Anna Donlon who's
apparently one of the executive
producers on project a used a number of
key phrases that tell me that they're
gonna try and meet in the middle between
csgo and overwatch phrases like precise
gunplay and high consequence gameplay
she also talks about low ping and server
tick rates and honestly it's kind of
shocking in a good way to see a
publisher take these kinds of issues
seriously then there's obviously the
cheating issue which they address and
hey if you still play matchmaking like I
do it's kind of relevant she also made a
comment that they want to evolve the
tactical shooter and make one with a lot
more style and I gotta be honest as a CS
fan hurts and a lot of UCS fans will be
happy to hear that the guns look
relatively realistic they're not laser
guns they're not cartoonish rocket
launchers they mimic if not perfectly
replicate real-world weaponry just take
a look at this play for example this
dude flicks on to a [ __ ] with
his Scout drop some kind of wind magic
ball thing which is basically just a
smoke when you think about it
then he self boosts to snipe another guy
with ninja stars but you know maybe
that's like the USP of this game or
something another thing to get excited
about if you're a CS fan or just a
fanboy of the hardcore shooter genre is
the involvement of Sal garosu Sal better
known in some circles as volcano is of
course a former CS pro and one of the
designers of a little csgo map called
cash he's currently listed as a senior
game designer at riot and honestly if
volcano's involved I heal
a lot better about project day now that
being said the graphics are a bit fat
and chunky for my taste but honestly
this is very early days and this is like
alpha footage so a lot of this can
change between now and the time the
games actually released call me crazy
guys I'm actually cautiously optimistic
about project a alright before I let
Keith cap stick takeover and tell you
all about League of Legends and card
games and all that [ __ ] there is a
hidden gem in this announcement that I
think got kind of buried with all the
other big ones and that is League of
Legends eSports manager I'm dead serious
as funny as it may sound I actually
think this announcement is kind of sick
if you've ever played like a football
manager game or maybe that csgo manager
that was in beta and steam and took an
entire day of my life a couple years ago
then you know how addicting these can be
and if you are into League of Legends
and you know my condolences if that's
the case and you don't want to drop 45
minutes a nights on some bronze League
game and get frustrated and rage quit
this is for you this is a way that you
can interact with the game you love in a
time frame that's a little more
realistic this game is like how to play
League of Legends for adults maybe and
honestly as a 31 year old I appreciate
that
now that we've talked about this and
we've covered the all-important FPS
entry I think that's everything that's
important about this announcement so
Matt if you wouldn't mind rolling the
credits we can end this video all right
hold on Colin could not be more wrong
because you have to see what they've
done with TFT League of Legends and a
brand new card game also I don't know
what the [ __ ] Colin's problem is because
six months ago he was asking me for tips
about how to get better at magic so
let's start with Ryan's new card game
which admittedly has a kind of strange
name legends of runeterra I gotta be
honest when I first saw this
announcement I was caught off guard
I thought teamfight tactics was the
closest thing we were gonna get to a
real car game from Ryan that said as
someone who spends their weekends
traveling around playing competitive
magic the gathering I am stoked to see a
real card game and they actually want to
step further by dropping the game in
closed beta last night right after the
announcement with streamers like Tice
kripp and disguise toast for what I can
tell from the small amount of the game
I've digested so far it's more or less
built around legal
Legends champions you build your deck
around the special abilities that those
champions have and that's going to
inform the way that your deck plays in
general we're also six regions in the
game which determine kind of what each
card can and can't do and they're
similar to the five colors in magic
other than that it's similar to other
digital PSG's we've seen from major
developers like hearthstone or artifact
basically you got one side and the other
side and the cards just smack into each
other your goal is to reduce your
opponent's life total to zero and then
their Nexus explodes
my main concern as a card game fan is
I'm not actually sure what separates
this from other titles in the scene
obviously tons of people love the
characters in League of Legends but is
that really enough to just do another
hearthstone clone that said one thing
that I do really like in the early
stages is that this game seems actually
really cheap deployed from what I gather
you're actually more likely to build a
big collection by playing a bunch not
putting a bunch of money into the game
as many of you know the economy ends up
being a huge deal whenever a new card
game comes up you guys remember the
catastrophic disaster that was artifact
the game is set to release in 2020 and
like I said is in close beta right now
and like all in the FBS I'm cautiously
optimistic about this one obviously for
me it's gonna be hard for this kind of
game to keep up with magic but the fact
that riots taking the time to build out
these regions and build the game around
characters means that it seems like it
could be fun in the longer and the fact
is people love League of Legends they
love all these characters and new ways
to sort of play around with them is
always gonna bring attention so let's
hope this one doesn't suck like almost
every other card game that comes in all
right now let's move on to riots bread
and butter for the last decade
League of Legends buried beneath what
seems like a mountain of brand-new games
they actually made a huge change to
league that's coming in 2020 they've
added what they're calling elemental
rifts which are supposed to contribute
to the current elemental Drake system
basically what happens is as your team
picks up Drake's like you normally
wouldn't League now you're gonna be
making permanent effects on the map and
honestly they look pretty [ __ ] wild
infernal knocks down walls and burns
down brush Mountain adds new terrain to
play around
ocean makes brush grow larger and spawn
extra honey fruit and cloud turns
pathways into wind tunnels that increase
movement speed despite this being a
relatively small change to a
pre-existing game this might be the
biggest impact on eSports from the
entire announcement the fact is all of
the players were watching at Worlds
right now are gonna have to deal with a
huge meta shift when this comes in
because those late games are going to be
crazy so far from the community there
have been some concerns about how random
this is all gonna be much like there was
when the elemental Drake's came out in
the first place but they look pretty
cool so let's hope they work at all
right so the last thing I have for you
is changes to TFT which is going mobile
turns out you guys actually do you have
phones and you know what that means this
is gonna be a massive [ __ ] cash cow
for riot for the years to come the fact
is mobile games have a huge casual
appeal and this is going to allow riot
to sort of sink into teamfight tactics
and with the move to mobile they also
announced that they're going to be doing
seasonal set releases the first one
comes out in about a week and has 50 new
units to the game and so this is gonna
massively shake-up tf2 like everything
from this announcement this seems like a
massive commitment to tf2 and despite
the fact that riots been sort of locked
away working for 10 years now they have
5 new games that they want to compete
with all of their competitors so I don't
know about you guys but I'm interested
to see if riot can handle all of these
games popping off and that's it for me
talking about card games and coffee
table games and everything that's
changing about League of Legends for our
last section we wanted to bring in our
resident weeb daniel rossen so he can
talk to you about all things anime it's
not an anime I'll start with that one of
their announcements was a new animated
show and the League of Legends universe
called arcane and the most important
thing about it is again it's not an
anime it's being made in the West by
Riot with CG animation it doesn't
qualify as an anime by like any metric I
should know I literally wrote a video
about being a weed anyway the show does
look cool it's gonna be an origin story
for I think jinx and VY and maybe
Warwick I don't know a lot about legal
war but the animation does look nice and
the voice-acting seem good the trailer
was really well cut so maybe it'll be
solved but the thing I'm actually more
interested and excited about is
fighting game codenamed project L we've
known about this game or at least heard
rumors about it for a very long time
going back to Anna Riot bought a
development studio called a radiant
entertainment way back in March 2015
radiant was working on this really cool
fighting game called a rising thunder
after they put out the Alpha for a tribe
autumn because it was at least partially
inspired by MOBAs instead of having
complicated quarter-circle or deep
emotions for your special moves it sort
of had one button specials with
cooldowns a lot like your spell's and
Uighur dota anyway we don't know a ton
about project elves specifically it's
being developed by a lot of old-school
fighting game personalities and
community members like tom and tony
cannon who were part of the co-founding
team of Evo and they say that they're
going in the dark about this for a while
but here's what we do know about project
out we saw four playable characters re
various Katarina and jinx and the game
has a lot of fighting game standards it
has health bars for each character a
stun gauge or a guard meter underneath
that round counters a timer something
that looks like the Street Fighter II X
bar but segmented into four segments and
maybe some kind of personal character
gauge sort of like what characters have
in injustice o also re totally has a
horas fireball animation from King of
Fighters and that's pretty much all we
know if I were a betting man I'd say
that it was a 1v1 fighter sort of
similar to Street Fighter or even rising
Thunder but that's as far as my
speculation will go I have no idea how
many buttons it uses we saw people
playing on keyboard but we also saw a
lot of fight sticks on people's desks
and on those arcade machines that they
showed in the video and I have no idea
if they kept the rising Thunder one
button specials or they're going to more
traditional fighting game style of
inputs but given the pedigree of the
developers working on it I'm sure that
it's in good hands I'm really interested
to see how it turns out and perhaps more
importantly how riot can interface with
the existing fighting game community
League of Legends hasn't been a
grassroots game in a very long time but
a hotter fighting game success is tied
to that grassroot scene
I don't know how riot can play nice with
the fgc but I'm hopeful because I really
like a fighting game with good net code
for once in my life then there's wild
rift a ground-up remake of League of
Legends 5 e 5 some
rift mode for consoles and mobile phones
and it actually looks really cool it was
designed for a dual stick play and kind
of reminds me of how Diablo 3 worked on
consoles which is to say pretty well
it also looks a lot nicer than standard
PC League they mentioned that they had
to do visual reworks of a lot of
characters from the ground up to make
them work in this style and you can
really tell graphically it looks really
impressive but I'm more interested to
see how it feels because I don't think
anybody's really ever gotten a full
scale mobile working on console oh also
riot announced a game codenamed project
F which they described as a very early
development project that explores the
possibilities of traversing the world of
runeterra with your friends
that tells us literally nothing but it
looks like an action RPG and hey you can
play as Blitzcrank who's like one of the
10 cooler League characters I guess
alright I think that's it for all of
Riots 1 billion announcements I hope
that we gave you guys a good idea of
everything that's going on and
contextualizing it and I hope you
enjoyed watching the three of us in the
same room because let me tell you
putting this together was [ __ ]
difficult thanks for watching if you
want more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages